bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de 7,8 le journal au sommaire ce
soir opération informations et
sécurisation menée par la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
ce mardi explications sur le déploiement
en cours menée par les forces de police
dans le département
l'université de versailles saint quentin
a enfreint adopter son budget pour
l'année 2015 c'était il ya tout juste
quelques minutes nous faisons le point
dans cette édition avec le président de
l'université le recensement est
obligatoire il va démarrer ce 15 janvier
pour certaines communes
saint-quentinoise olemps verrière nous
avons suivi le travail de formation de
ses agents recenseurs avant leur passage
au domicile des habitants le plan
vigipirate alerte attentat est déployé
sur l'ensemble du territoire qu'est ce
que cela veut dire concrètement sur le
terrain en milieu d'après-midi et chose
peu courante les services départementaux
de la sécurité publique ont mené une
opération d'information de sécurisation
aux abords de la gare de versailles
chantiers ils ont donc détaillé
l'organisation de ce plan vigipirate
appliquée dans tous les lieux de
rassemblement centres commerciaux gares
château de versailles y compris certains
quartiers qui sont surveillés de près
une réunion quotidienne avec le préfet
et tous les chefs de service police et
gendarmerie ont lieu actuellement pour
faire le point sur la situation
et puis à noter aussi au sein des
services de police tous les congés sont
actuellement suspendus ainsi que les
formations et le personnel de bureau
sont également mobilisés sur le terrain
les explications avec jean pierre
salanova c'est le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique au
micro d'anthony rice et patriotisme les
policiers qui patrouillent
sur la voie publique ou dans les lieux
publics doivent faire tout d'abord
attention aux éventuelles menaces des
comportements atypiques de la part de
personnes des colis piégés par exemple
ils doivent également se rendre
disponible auprès de la population afin
de renseigner et de rassurer l'élément
qui consiste à devoir rassurer la
population est très importante il faut
éviter les psychoses et les peurs
l'inutile irraisonnée
que pensez-vous de l'utilité du plan
vigipirate c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines voici vos
réponses
beaucoup plus de policiers de deux
contrôles dans tous les lieux publics et
de deux militaires et leur présence et
leur présence à ratio mine de rien c'est
pas utile parce que pour moi s'il va
faire quelque chose ils peuvent déjouer
le plan vigipirate donc
c'est très important pour nous protéger
ça me semble cruciale en ce moment j'ai
pas vu tellement la police pendant cette
histoire de vigipirate je livre le
centre commercial j'ai pas été contrôlée
plus que ça donc je trouve que c'est
assez laxiste assez fort utile parce que
les forces de l'ordre seront d'une part
en première ligne pour nous protéger et
c'est utile mais
malheureusement ça dure pas longtemps je
pense que c'est très utile à l'heure
actuelle parce qu'on vit une période un
petit peu mouvementée et donc on sent un
petit peu plus en sécurité
ou alors le sens des avis toutefois
partagés parmi les concitoyens
interviewé cet après-midi dans les rues
de saint quentin on passe à
l'enseignement supérieur à 17 voix pour
huit voix contre une abstention le
budget 2015 de l'université de
versailles saint quentin a été voté ce
mardi en fin d'après midi le point avec
florent parfait et william l
des grilles fermées une chaîne et un
filtrage à l'entrée seuls les membres du
conseil d'administration sont autorisés
à entrer au siège de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin des mesures
prises pour éviter les débordements du
mois de décembre où des étudiants
s'étaient invités au conseil
d'administration pour témoigner de leur
crainte des craintes à propos du budget
2015 toujours d'actualité
me la priorité je laisse complètement de
côté du coup il fallait taper du poing
sur la table cette fois c'est ce que je
vais leur dire c'est en gros soyez avec
nous n'acceptez pas l'austérité dans les
budgets ne soyez avec nous revendiquez
vous aussi le fait que l'état redonne de
l'argent plus d'argent chaque année pour
pallier aux dépenses obligatoires et
qu'on arrête de couper dans les
formations que les étudiants arrête de
payer des pots cassés quoi
l'unef n'a pas prévu aujourd'hui
d'envahir la réunion de vote et
symbolique le budget de l'université est
sous tutelle du rectorat un plan
d'économies a été mis en place des
filières ont été fermés comme la licence
staps à versailles des économies lourde
de conséquences selon le syndicat cgt
nous avons des personnels qui sont
partis de leur plein gré vu l'état de
l'université et le budget qui est
effectivement
insuffisant nous ne revendique à sion
sont de bien sûr demandé aux ministères
plus d'argent pour que nous puissions
fonctionner simplement correctement
sarr qu'actuellement l'année dernière
nous avons fonctionné avec 25% de budget
pour les labos et actuellement nous
avons il a été voté et décidée par la
direction 1
un budget à 50% pour les labos du côté
des enseignants ne comprends pas bien
ces réductions juge est facultative avec
ses budgets ils s'attendent à une
situation légèrement meilleur qu'en 2014
mais sans grande satisfaction léonie 15
va être une année difficile encore pour
les personnels et pour faire fonctionner
et tourner nos informations c'est
incontestable tout ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est que le ministère en prennent à un
moment un autre vraiment conscience qu'à
du vécu comme ailleurs nous sommes dans
une sous dotation qui est chronique
maintenant et qu'il n'est plus qui n'est
pas tenable sur le long terme si nous
avons des budgets compresser des budgets
réduits ce n'est pas parce qu'il faut
faire plus d'économies dans l'absolu
c'est parce que le gouvernement fait le
choix de donner six milliards et demi en
crédit impôt recherche sur des
dispositifs dont tout le monde sait en
tout cas beaucoup le disent qu'ils sont
plutôt relativement inefficace on c'est
ça la vraie la vraie clé je dirai après
100 live rien en fait que dans chaque
établissement il ya des choix à faire
des choix politiques de gestion a aucun
problème avec ça le conseil
d'administration a duré plusieurs heures
dans l'après midi du budget a été voté
résultats messieurs pour 8 contre et une
abstention
donc je rappelle que ce budget 2015
n'avait pas pu être voté une première
fois le 16 décembre dernier il avait été
annulé en raison d'un rassemblement
d'étudiants notamment qu'ils
s'opposaient aux économies là on l'a vu
il a été voté en fin d'après midi on a
en téléphone avec mme joly ce vestiaire
bonsoir
vous êtes le président de l'université
de versailles saint quentin le budget
vient d'être tout juste
voté 17 voix contre 8
dix sept doigts pour pardon lui contre
l'abstention également vous êtes un
président satisfait
18% pour moi d'avoir la communauté pu
faire bouger après on peut toujours dire
j'aurais aimé pouvoir offrir plus à la
communauté de deux buts et un examen
aussi on avait trop peu d'emplois
j'aurais aimé qu'il soit plus fin
on regardait contrainte je pense qu'on
se débrouille pas trop mal dans quel
état d'esprit s'est déroulé ce conseil
d'administratio l'ambiance
débattre des charges et en profondeur si
je puis dire sur la pratique
du but et d'une cave également comme en
vrai avenir comment on évolue comme on
dit et
on redémarre mois de position dans le
périmètre de paris saclay c'est très
intéressant donc
globalement c'était un soutien
de la communauté des professeurs des
était là avec des écritures bien sûr que
partager mais bon je pensais tout
conscient tourner leurs partitions
dynamique
positive
je
vous parle effectivement de médiateur se
rappeler que vous aviez d'abord présenté
un budget en déficit comment est la
différence avec ce budget de 2015 en
2014 avait bénéficié d'une aide
exceptionnelle de l'état est ce que là
c'est le cas pour ce budget 2015 non là
donc
avec un bénéfice à faire l'état positive
mais deux cercles 1 millions d'euros
mais sachant qu'on a eu 2 millions 6
euros d'avancés remboursables
du mystère
il a remboursé
sera construit à l'équilibré tout seul
attendez
donc on se rendre compte à combien
s'élève un budget à d'université comme
la venue
de refaire le dépenser le budget initial
donc le 13 janvier s'est offerte
millions d'euros 5 en 149 millions
quelles économies vous a dû vous avez dû
faire entre 2014 et 2015 les syndicats
la fois des étudiants et des enseignants
dénoncent effectivement des baisses de
moyens
oui donc justement
on verra pas les 800 100 d'évaluation
des dépenses ou moins de 28 ans après il
faudra aussi travailler sur la façon
dont il ya eu des contre-attaqués fort
sur les emplois soit rafael
également sur les frais de
fonctionnement hormonal réduit les
heures de 14 il ya du très fortement à
du thé des portes de fonctionnement donc
en 2015 on a réaugmenté on a plus
augmenté les dépenses de fonctionnement
n'est pas forcément à la hauteur de ce
que tout un chacun vous êtes et après
bon moyen des contrats qui pourrissent
et sera ré six filets c'était continue à
persister ce qu'elle dit qu'elle est
toujours en a deux beaux succès
logique tu deviens un peu sous la
contrainte ça rend un peu innovant et
créatif qu'on arrive à trouver les
moyens même si ça répond pas à toutes
les questions a les situations qui était
très problématique pour 2010 en
2012-2013 bon sens la tête de l'eau on
continue à avancer inclure la réduction
la discussion sincère ce
jeudi après midi pour témoigner pour
vous montrer l'exemple de récit de notre
énergie est le fait des collectes vous
avez parlé à deux adversaires
paris-saclay de décret a été publié pour
sa création le 31 décembre dernier à 19
établissements parmi lesquels
l'université mais aussi hc université
paris-sud centrale polytechnique il
n'est rien je vais pas tous les citer en
tout cas c'est des grands noms qui sont
réunis sur un même territoire comment
l'université va évoluer dans cette
université paris saclay ce que c'est
l'occasion justement pour vous d'obtenir
des nouveaux moyens
cette fois le kg l'occasion aux
différents le point avec sa collègue la
clé sur un
bon ça nous a rapporté sur chez sur le
secteur l'activité du club ces trois
hommes neuf cent mille euros pour
s'épanouir donc c'est effectivement
par rapport à l'inspection sur le budget
c'est une source de moyens sur la
recherche la formation pour les
étudiants de sa mort à coup sûr les
travaux pratiques innovantes sur le
numérique sur des flux et les dépose de
stage sur des bourses de mobilité
internationale donc voilà c'est d'une
part cet aspect là tu notre part c'est
pouvoir travailler développer vos
projets avec kangoo tiges et les écoles
universités prestigieuses donc je suis
très content que mes collègues
considèrent que
que des sacs et cosider a
accepté avec enthousiasme je dirais
draveurs chez l'action
et vous irez pardon du vestiaire juste
pour conclure à l'université est sortie
de la crise mais pas complètement encore
il faut encore maintenir cet équilibre
budgétaire toujours un peu délicat quoi
on a cru bon je pense qu'on est sorti la
crise d'après en est on est dans une
situation des coeurs enfin bon je pense
que la patine à cette situation je pense
à pékin le pays qu'ils allaient se joint
un petit peu compliqué alors méfiance
voire de finance privée donc on est
aussi l'image que tu peux y voir du
territoire parce que tout un chacun
connaît des problèmes je pensais qu ici
aussi des soucis de financement
voilà après le tout ces listes en sus
qui a présenté tout voir la pièce c'est
par mourir elle s'adapter pour survivre
pour
bat pour un futur
tube leurs yeux c'est ce que je pense
c'est le message que vous délivrerez
jeudi à l'occasion des voeux oui le zoom
est
optimiste je pense qu'on a plein de
qualités qu'on m'explique les maj 2 bat
pour que notre université a possible
malisse bel sera prêté un peu moins dans
développement quantitatif augmenter les
surfaces et puis dans le qualitatif
faire est très attentif à la qualité de
la formation à la qualité de la
recherche de l'innovation et comme j'ai
des hawks et admiration le tout à
l'heure devant les élus territoriaux
dans ce merdier de lui en cours et elle
emprunte à tous et général c'est que
nous montrer les entreprises créent des
entreprises l'un sur le territoire
ils ont créé des emplois créés d'emploi
cbe ses missions son rôle dans le
développement économique
et social joue
merci en tout cas je n'ai bien sûr a
répondu à nos questions et puis donc une
diversité plus qualitatives que
quantitatives sont en tout cas le
message qu'on aura bien retenu de votre
part merci beaucoup à vous
on continue on va parler maintenant
recensement à partir du 15 janvier
plusieurs communes de saint quentin en
yvelines vont être recensés et ce
jusqu'au 14 février
ici le premier jour de recensement les
agents reçoivent de la part de ligne
c'est un des formations comme à la
verrière mélanie bocquet et l'oni mme
elodie moines pardon ont assisté à une
de ses réunions
en liste à sur la feuille de logement
ici les gens renseignements toutes les
personnes qui vivent en permanence dans
le logement et il y aura autant de buts
individuel que deux personnes qui seront
assorties de la dernière journée de
préparation pour ces agents recenseurs à
partir de jeudi ils arpenteront les rues
de la commune pour recueillir les
données des habitants et c'est toute une
organisation
dans un premier temps je vais essayer
entre midi et deux au moins les deux
premières semaines le soir en sortant
dont vers 17h30 jusqu'à un maximum 20h
20h30 et le samedi de 11 heures à 15
heures et à près de 17 heures vers 20h30
aussi voilà le dimanche matin ils vont
pleinement si ça dérange pas les gens
sur la verrière ils sont dix à être
autorisé à enquêter équipé d'une carte
officielle permettant de les identifier
lors de leur première journée de
formation ils sont partis en
reconnaissance pour informer les
habitants le recensement permet
d'établir en partie la contribution de
l'état au budget des communes c'est
important pour d'autres choses en
commune à connaître en fin de compte les
caractéristiques
des logements d'une part de la commune
et puis les personnes pour prendre des
décisions par exemple pour une crèche
des maisons de retraite au niveau du
transport domicile travail
toutes les informations recueillies sont
anonymes et protégez vous avez aussi la
possibilité de vous recensez par
internet l'enquète se fera jusqu'au 14
février et c'est obligatoire
et on va continuer à parler budget un
budget en tout cas qui a du mal à passer
c'est celui du ministère de la culture
on dirait que c'est des musiques
actuelles treize fédérations syndicats
au réseau du secteur des musiques
actuelles dont le cri le centre de
ressources yvelinois interpelle donc le
la ministre de la culture sur le
déséquilibre engendrés par le budget
alloué à la fameuse philharmonie
supérieur aux projections budgétaires
pour les lieux de musiques actuelles son
ensemble du territoire pour nous
expliquer tout ça au téléphone avec nous
se retirer du val bonsoir vous êtes
directeur du cri alors le 14 janvier la
philharmonie à paris c'est la salle
dédiée aux musiques classiques sur le
parc de la villette qu'on peut
d'ailleurs découvrir du périphérique 1
c'est un bâtiment à l'architecturé un
peu particulière et donc ce bâtiment va
être inauguré les projections du
ministère de la culture inscrits pour
2015 9 millions d'euros pour les autres
cultures actuelles son ensemble du
territoire et 9,8 millions d'euros pour
la seule philharmonie c'est un peu tout
cela vous voulez dénoncer dans ce
courrier vous adresser à la ministre de
la culture voilà donc fait une lettre
ouverte effectivement à l'adresse d'une
hyper bien évidemment responsable de la
philharmonie partager avec l'ensemble
des médias des acteurs du secteur
culturel d'ailleurs ce qu'on démontre
effectivement le fait depuis 25 ans bat
collectivement pour faire reconnaître
toutes les actions de s'emmener par nos
yeux nos réseaux les salles de concert
les foudres est pétition en faveur des
gens qui pratiquent la musique ce qu'on
appelle une petite actuelle dans notre
pays et que ce sera de 5 ans qu'on me
dit que c'était compliqué que les
budgets sont réduits à des difficultés
qu'à la crise est là on voit débouler en
quelque sorte une institution déficit
par un petit groupe de personnes
passionnées de musique classique qui
fait en fait à l'arrivée
à budget d'investissement 4 millions
d'euros et un budget annuel de
fonctionnement en tout cas une
subvention annuelle de faire de la
culture de notre millions d'euros qui
effectivement correspond à l'ensemble
des dotations du ministère de la culture
pour les deux musiques actuelles au
front national
les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes serre
que vous vous demandez à avoir plus ou
un écran grâce this fait passer ça on
demande à voir plus depuis 25 ans donc
c'est pas nouveau simplement ça témoigne
un petit peu delà du décalage qui existe
entre les moeurs musical de nos
concitoyens avec des engagements
musicaux qui vont et ce que
l'institution ait certaines personnes
font de vous de développer en termes de
politique culturelle c'est surtout ça
qu'on dénonce c'est à dire que on a là
un équipement qui est avant tout le
projet de quelques personnes puisque
donc il existait déjà un certain nombre
de salles de musique la situer très
performante à paris et dans la région et
à côté de ça si vous voulez depuis 25
ans on a du mal dans notre petite
structure à tour et les moyens de
subsister mener à bien les actions qui
répondent aux besoins des musiciens sur
les territoires avant de répéter se
former et faire des concerts et donc
c'est ce décalage et 7
n'hésite pas à qualifier en quelque
sorte surtout les prix qu'on dénonce à
travers ce communiqué justement comment
les lieux de musiques de musiques
actuelles sont financés actuellement est
ce que vous percevez évidemment des
subventions de l'état est ce que ça vous
suffit pour pour vivre non très peu en
fait qu on a surtout des subventions des
collectivités territoriales puisque donc
j'ai dit les départements et la région
ile-de-france sont plus près si vous
voulez du terrain et élus locaux ouvrent
bien tout l'intérêt d'adapter un petit
peu les équipements on appelle les
musiques actuelles pour répondre aux
besoins des populations des mélomanes
des musiciens donc c'est plutôt à
travers ses institutions de terrain
qu'on a des soutiens l'état
effectivement a mis en place un label
s'adresse aux musiques actuelles depuis
maintenant bientôt vingt ans mais qui
comme vous le disais dans les chiffres
peine à atteindre
qui va être l'équivalent des subventions
de la philharmonie donc effectivement on
réclame surtout il discussions et
surtout ce qui est très important c'est
un acte démocratique terre ce qui se
passe c'est que les décisions sur les
politiques culturelles se prennent dans
un entre soi de quelques personnes et
nous ce qu'on demande c'est que les
populations les habitants soient
consultés puisse participer
en tout cas aux décisions de ce qui va
tenir en oeuvre localement pourquoi
voyez un petit peu ça le problème c'est
que on est dans un domaine où y'a pas la
démocratie participative et pas vraiment
à le droit pendant que les dix à treize
fédérations et qui a envoyé ce courrier
au ministère de la culture c'est quoi
ces treize fédérations alors on connaît
le cri bien sûr mais notre fédération
sait alors ce rassemblement c'est
l'initiative et le réseau régional
s'appelle laury et en ile de france qui
fédère les huit réseaux départementaux
équivalent au prix contraint à peu près
250 structures musicales sur l'île de
france à côté de ça il ya les
fédérations nationales comme la fédé
d'imac qui rassemble les yeux musiques
actuelles la fneje m'a donc chez paypal
une influence jazz zone franche en tout
cas toutes les fédérations qui rassemble
des acteurs des musiques actuelles au
niveau national plus des réseaux
régionaux ça soit dans le nord de la
france dans le centre dans le sud est à
peu près tous les acteurs se mobilisent
pour mettre en plus par interpeller
l'ensemble de la population et surtout
les élus les responsables politiques sur
ce qui se passe actuellement qui nous
semble
assez dit du chien la valeur vous
souhaitez un rendez-vous et 2005 culture
alors bien voilà c'est qu'on souhaite à
l'occasion de l'inauguration de et de
l'ouverture de cet équipement manifester
notre désapprobation faire savoir que
c'est quand même difficilement
supportable d'être
cantonné dans les formes de précarité
depuis 20 ans et voir dans une période
de crise qui touche tout le monde ça va
au delà de la question de la culture des
équipements budgétivore comme ça qu'ils
sortent de terre et qui sera encore une
fois le ch lui quelques personnes un
groupuscule de personnes qui pensent que
c'était beau dans la gérer dans la
conquête mondiale et dans la la
compétition mondiale à qui aura tué
l'équipement de faire la philharmonie à
paris d'accord mais merci en tout cas
dire du mal être intervenu sur mer sur
le bateau du journal donc vous serez pas
14 janvier à la halle inauguration en
tout cas si je serai peut-être devant
pour manifester en tout cas voilà merci
beaucoup
allez on continue avec une information
aux politiques cette fois-ci parmi
toutes les institutions politiques
conseil municipal régional général ou
senna acquis feriez vous le plus
confiance et bien le cevipof le centre
de recherches politiques de sciences po
vient de remettre son baromètre de la
confiance politique dans les
institutions une enquête réalisée auprès
de mille huit cent soixante quatre
personnes représentatif de la population
française âgée de plus de 18 ans
inscrits à la liste électorale enquête
réalisée entre le 5 et le 15 décembre
2014 si pour toutes les précisions eh
bien vous le voyez sur ces images le
conseil municipal 66% des personnes
interrogées font confiance à leur
conseil municipal 7 + 4 points en un an
54% leur conseil régional 53% alors
conseil général et seulement 23% des
personnes interrogées font confiance à
leur gouvernement en baisse de deux
points par rapport au dernier baromètre
mais ça c'était un sondage qui datait du
mois de décembre 2014 allez santé
maintenant des trappistes s'étaient
mobilisés il y a quelques semaines pour
soutenir le maintien du centre médical
albert schweitzer et dénoncé le manque
de médecins généralistes donc sur la
commune de trappes les pétitions
d'ailleurs circulé leur ai déjà
recueilli 2000 signatures le centre
implanté en centre centre médical
implanté en centre ville qui compte
quatre médecins bien fermera bien ses
portes au mois de juin prochain il a été
cédé un promoteur immobilier et dans un
article paru chez nos confrères des
nouvelles le maire de trappes guy
malandain dit s'être rapproché de l'
agence régionale de santé et de la
communauté d'agglomération pour trouver
des solutions l'agglomération qui étudie
la possibilité d'ouvrir des maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires début 2007
pour résoudre en partie le problème des
déserts médicaux
depuis ce lundi 12 janvier le centre
multi accueil de la petite enfance
poulbot a ouvert ses portes cet accueil
en cours c'est le deuxième équipement de
ce type sur la commune avec une capacité
d'accueil de 22 enfants cette structure
aux horaires plus flexibles aucune
crèche traditionnelle peut accueillir
les enfants dont les deux parents
travaillent avec des horaires
spécifiques ou dont les nos parents
n'ont pas d'emploi la structure propose
également une sorte de système halte
garderie
pour les enfants dit ponctuelles ce qui
permet de garder seulement quelques
heures dans la journée ses enfants il
reste encore quelques places et je vous
propose d'écouter galette tranquard
c'est la directrice de la crèche ont ça
répond à une demande de parents d'emploi
du temps
enfin les parents ont un emploi du temps
atypique donc ça peut être par exemple
des infirmières qui travaillent de nuit
dont qui ont besoin de dormir un peu
matin mais qu'on pas besoin de toute la
journée où on a aussi des profs des
profs qui vont avoir travaillé trois
heures le lundi 4 heures le jeudi voilà
cdd contrats ou des compléments de garde
aussi ça veut dire que ça peut être les
papys mamies qui garde les enfants et
donc nous on peut accueillir de 2 jours
pour soulager les grands-parents ou
voilà ça peut être des choses comme ça
cette nouvelle édition du journal est
maintenant terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi rendez vous demande directe à 18
heures nous avons nous recevons
notamment le président de la communauté
d'agglomération michel auger maire de
montigny dans quelques instants je vous
donne rendez-vous pour le 7-8 société
nous donnerons la parole aux communautés
religieuses après les actes terroristes
survenus en france je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée